les gens ne connaissent pas ils me
connaissent à travers ce qu'ils peuvent
voir de moi toutes les discriminations
quelques sous elles ont pas de place et
pan dans le football et dans le sport en
général quand on se voit déjà arriver de
la pataterie gp mais aussi
[Musique]
j'ai passé par là aujourd'hui et les
champs bonjour merci d'accorder cette
interview la brute
vous êtes originaire de bayonne à la
base du sud terre de rugby comment vous
allez vers et autres boules par le rugby
j'ai joué au rugby aussi j'étais très
sport j'ai fait un peu tous les sports
je fais de l'athlétisme du cross du
handball j'ai joué au rugby je préférais
lors du sud où le football donc voilà
j'ai choisi un moment il a fallu que je
choisisse très tôt puisque j'avais 14
ans et j'ai été sollicité pour intégrer
un centre de formation j'ai dû prendre
la décision de modifier ma trajectoire
c'est à dire qui était d'abord étude
pour voir après ce que j'aurais pu faire
mais là c'était un choix déjà important
très tôt de d'intégrer le centre de
formation de nantes et l'annuaire
m'avait carrément sur tellement plus
qu'un corps ne pense pas ce que pour
arriver aussi qu'il est arrivé il a
fallu keur gui qui l'envoyaient c'est à
dire que j'en ai bavé
lui l'a certainement plus bavé comme moi
pour d'autres raisons parce qu'il
fallait nourrir la famille fallait
travailler dès fois sacrifié le week-end
pour connaît suffisamment pour bien mais
moi je n'ai pas d'avis à fait partie
choisit pas tout avoir dans la vie à
partir du moment où on fait le choix de
rentrer dans un centre de formation de
tout faire pour être professionnels
d'aller le plus haut possible mais ça
implique aussi nié d'avoir une hygiène
de vie un cadre de vie qui qui qui est
différent forcément les crises
ce n'est pas si j'arrive à regard soirée
de la veille ce carton rien du tout rien
ne fait pas de geste à la vie joue pas
mais vous pouvez lui parler la quasi
totalité des personnes qui disent me
connaître me connaissent à travers ce
qu'ils peuvent avoir deux mois
quand je suis dans mon rôle de deux
sélectionneurs ces dernières années ou
avant quand j'étais joueur mais c'est
pas forcément ce que je suis dans ma vie
au quotidien
selon l'exposition ces deux époques
différentes époques il est pas des
réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui on vaut quasiment en temps
réel la vie des joueurs pour le grand
bonheur de tout le monde mais quand ça
se passe bien c'est merveilleux c'est le
monde d'aujourd'hui c'est la
multiplication des médias et avec les
réseaux sociaux bien évidemment avec le
côté positif qui permet d'avoir des
images des émotions qu'on n'aurait pas
pu avoir
avant un instantané quasi instantanée
c'est le monde d'aujourd'hui
je me bats pas contre ça ça fait partie
de la vie même si moi personnellement
j'y suis pas agi j'y serai pas parce que
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'intérêts j'ai pas de
plaisir à y être ou de faire partager
mais c'est une question de génération
aussi les jeunes d'aujourd'hui s'est
montré ce qu'ils font avec ti sens où
ils sont moi je préfère ne pas savoir où
je suis avec qui je suis voilà mais
c'est le monde d'aujourd'hui je vais pas
lutter contre ça ça fait partie de la
vie médiatique aujourd'hui et
en tenant compte de l'évolution de cet
aspect la multiplication des médias et
des réseaux sociaux qui fait que
aujourd'hui la discrétion est de plus en
plus réduite et bien évidemment et
comment on gère son groupe
on l'a vu en 2018 dont les coupes du
monde où on suivait quasiment autour et
dans ce qui se passait comment vous en
tant que sélectionneur vous avez un
étrange où déjà confrontée à celle de
mill 2014 avec eux du monde au brésil je
interdire c'est impossible pour moi je
m'en veuillez pas intervenir que c'est
enlever une liberté qu'ils ont cette
liberté là après le plus important c'est
de pouvoir cadrer pour qu'ils ne se
mettent pas en difficulté qui met pas le
le groupe en difficulté ce que
représente l'équipe de france la
fédération et ce maillot
bleu-blanc-rouge et des fois quelque
chose qui peut faire rire sur le moment
avec le temps et très vite après peut
être quelque chose qui peut devenir très
vite une une polémique
quelque chose qui sûrement je vais
prendre un exemple je l' ai toujours
pris où on était au brésil en 2014
pendant la coupe du monde où les joueurs
avaient des temps libre on était dans un
cadre de base plutôt agréable où il y
avait des piscines et peuvent se prendre
en main en vidéo autour de la piscine il
sort au moment de de relâche il ya rien
eu mal mais les supporters français qui
sont en france et qui voit ça et si ça
se passe mal le match qu issu d'une
maison que ça à faire de faire de la
bronzette et rien faire autour de la
piscine
c'est un exemple mais c'est la réalité
donc c'est pas m quand il parle de ou
qu'ils se mettent eux
à l'image entre guillemets après libre à
eux en faisant attention à ce qu'ils
peuvent mettre aussi comme un
commentaire mais surtout pas mettre en
difficulté ou partenaires ou adversaires
ou d'institutions parce que
l'institution est au dessus de tous de
toute façon ma mère lui disait tout en
suivant jouent au baby foot ensemble et
le 10 mai laisse le gagner parce que moi
je pleurais quand je perdais et lui dit
non c'est comme ça qu'il apprendra moi
je dis là ce qu'on tient beaucoup à la
construction d'autres parcours c'est la
haine de la défaite est clairement le
fait jamais rien même quand vous jouez
avec vos deux fils c'est encore le cas
non pas après ça c'est plus ma vision de
l'éducation qui pas que c'est là la
bonne pour tout le monde mais et mon
fils reconnaît aujourd'hui que c'est
quelque chose qui me sert et qu'il qui
lui a servi qui lui sert et qui lui a
forgé un mental parce que moi aussi j'ai
été éduqué comme ça et ne pas voilà deux
d'être dans l'adversité de ça oblige à
aller puiser au plus profond de soi et
les qualités psychologiques et mentales
sont très importantes aussi dans le
sport de haut niveau à qualité égale
forcément après c'est le mental qui
étaient là qui fait la différence mais
ce qu'il veut pas dire que certains
papas peuvent éditer leurs fils dans une
dune manière et que le fils ne
réussissent pas ça très bien très bien
sa vie donc cédé une vision d'une forme
d'éducation qui peut réussir de certains
enfants mais qui peut ne pas être la
bonne avec d'autres c'est le moteur
justement vous possédez de nantes à
marseille alors il ya très longtemps
grosse pression des exigences pression
si on s'aime bien en fait aussi sentir
pareil oui c'est des mots carrière la
pression n'en sais pas les pc de
l'adrénaline
tout ce qui est négative moi j'aime pas
pression stress
non c'est de la dynamite de l'excitation
aprilia comment appréhende
l'environnement extérieur qui peut avoir
plus ou moins d' influence sur son sur
sa façon d'agir de réagir mais c'est pas
de la pression c'est de l'exigence soit
on veut rester là et où on a toujours
l'ambition d'aller plus haut si on voit
que nous il ya plus de six ans il ya
plus d'attentes
il faut toujours plus ou en se
contentant de se dire c'est très bien et
j'en reste là ça peut convenir mais
quand on veut toujours quand on fait
quelque chose de bien on peut toujours
faire mieux quand c'est très bien on
peut toujours qu'il ya toujours la
possibilité de de s'améliorer de faire
mieux même si ça a permis de réussir ou
de gagner c'est pas se contenter de ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on a fait c'est
s'enrichir se nourrir de ce qui a été
bien fait mais pouvoir encore améliorer
certaines choses et dans le le sport de
très haut niveau
voilà la formule les détails mais c'est
souvent mais des détails l'accumulation
de détails moi je pars du principe un
pour cent 2 % c'est pas grand chose mais
c'est 2% là je préfère les maîtres de
notre côté de plutôt que de les donner à
l'adversaire à marseille à une rencontre
celle d'un art qui dit souvent que dans
le football moderne il ya de moins en
moins justement deux dirigeants fort en
gueule ou charismatique époques
différentes et ce que aussi il pourrait
pas c'est pas possible de faire les
choses comme ça aujourd'hui c'est une
autre période notre génération de faire
des copier coller ce qui marchait il ya
dix ans il ya vingt ans ne marche pas
forcément aujourd'hui parce que on n'a
pas les mêmes personnes 1 en face paris
mêmes centres d'intérêt ne fonctionnent
pas de la même façon peut pas il faut il
ya un maître mot après dans tous les
domaines professionnels
quand on est dirigeant où on a une
responsabilité c'est s'adapter s'adapter
au contexte s'adapter aux personnes
qu'on a en face de soi avec leur
caractère leur personnalité
différentes ça a marché à ce moment là
parce que tout était réuni
certainement de par la personnalité des
uns et des autres mais c'est pas ceux
d'hier et au même moment refaire la même
chose à notre endroit
c'est pas forcément que ça aurait à coup
sûr bien marché aussi de ce franc parler
peut-être est-ce qu'il n'est plus
possible aujourd'hui parce que c'est la
vie oui aujourd'hui malheureusement
aujourd'hui chaque mot peut prendre
avoir des conséquences très importantes
donc aujourd'hui de la communication
prend une place essentielle et le
moindre mot que amenés à voter non suis
je m'adapte et c'est comme ça c'est pour
ça qu'il faut faire très attention à la
maîtrise mais de notre côté je vais pas
dire que je le subis mais l'
environnement médiatique sportif va donc
cet excès là où on va plus dans tout ce
qui est le plus agressif le plus violent
c'est pas c'est pas une bonne chose
c'est pas comme pousser une gueulante
c'est pas forcément aussi crier plus
fort que tout le monde on peut dire les
choses sans pour autant monter les
décibels c'est plus ce qui est le plus
important 1 c'est le choix des mots pour
moi et l'adéquation entre ce qu'on dit
et le visage vous avez souvent évoqué
votre fierté de jouer pour l'équipe de
france
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les jeux souffir
sentiment de fierté nationale
il existe encore chez les jeunes
générations on est très fort il est
redevenu très fort en ce moment ça avait
craint la courbe des résultats et
l'histoire l'historique de l'équipe de
france mais aujourd'hui depuis quelques
années oui ce
le säntis du moment où c'était plus ou
moins mais c'est par rapport à ce qui a
pu se passer avec des périodes plus ou
moins difficiles et cet attachement est
ce ce que représente ce maillot et
l'importance que peuvent avoir les
joueurs quand ils ont ce monsieur ce
maillot les devoirs qu'ils ont vis-à-vis
de 2,2 des supporters notamment de la
nouvelle génération j'aime pas le monde
exemplaire être exemplaire ça veut dire
que personne n'a le droit à l'erreur
mais ce sont des exemples et dans les
exemples qu'il ya de bons et de mauvais
set
il vaut mieux être de penser qu'on peut
pour déjà personne ne sera jamais au
dessus d'un collectif et tous les
joueurs qui peuvent être importants sont
importants à travers un collectif et un
moment dans une
dans un sport collectif il ya toujours
des équilibres avoir des équilibres
purement spécifique sur le terrain des
équilibres sociaux aussi ce qui m'amène
avec mon staff a beaucoup réfléchir
discuter échanger à un moment à prendre
des décisions comme gelée je les fais je
les assume
à chaque fois mais il y en a qui peuvent
qui n'ont pas été d'accord qui seront
pas d'accord mais ça ça fait partie de
mes ça me gêne pas je suis là pour
choisir autrement je ferai un autre
métier quand on choisit pas on n'a pas
de problème tout le monde est d'accord
mais à partir du moment où on choisit on
parle toujours de ce ce qui me concerne
quand je suis une sélection on va
toujours me parler de ce que j'ai pas
pris mais si j'avais prise que j'ai pas
vraiment parlerai de ce que j'aurai pas
pris aussi c'est pas très clair mais
vous m'avez compris et si justement on
avait un conseil à donner à cette jeune
génération dont le comportement dans
l'attitude à avoir pour ali a pas de
pensée en commission avec des centres
d'intérêts différents modes de
fonctionnement différent mais pourquoi
voir que le côté négatif
elle a aussi beaucoup beaucoup de de
qualité cette jeune génération qu'on
avait peut-être pas la mienne et celle
d'avant aujourd'hui veulent tout tout de
suite
ils ont cette faculté a ses raisons de
partir d'aller à l'étranger jeunes il
n'y a pas de soucis avant c'était
quelque chose qui était quand même on
était quand même le plus fort réticents
ils ont une énorme confiance en eux l
affaire commence en 98 quand un
entraîneur du championnat italien
s'étonne de l'impressionnante évolution
physique de certains joueurs de la
juventus de turin
une enquête est ouverte la police
perquisitionne alors les locaux de la
juve ils découvrent une pharmacie digne
des plus grands hôpitaux
à l'époque le procureur a auditionné
tous les joueurs de la juve dont didier
deschamps à trois reprises à la juventus
ou ailleurs il n'ya jamais eu dépôt ou
quoi que ce soit le ils seront peut-être
convaincu de certaines choses moi je
suis tranquille de ce côté là je n'ai
jamais pris de produits illicites durant
ma carrière parce que j'en avais pas
besoin de toute façon on italie résume
tous peut-être un chapitre qui avait
fait beaucoup parler à l'époque c'était
les soupçons de dopage
comment vous vivez cette période à ce
moment là un des toutes ces réalisations
révélation c on est pris dans le jeu
dira également dans le tambour d'une
machine à laver ses prix des dents mais
aujourd'hui on peut en reparler j'ai pas
tous iressa cccd des affaires qui ont
été jugés donc il n'y a pas à revenir
dessous après il y en a certains qui
peuvent dire oui mais il ya une des
choses terre-net la justice a rendu son
verdict à partir du moment où la justice
rend son verdict il n'ya pas revenir
dessus c'est le le principe de base même
si sur le moment
forcément c'est des choses qui sont
désagréables
parce que voilà il ya le doute la remise
en cause comme c'est souvent le cas
quand il ya quelque chose de négatif ça
va aussi dans l'excès c'est jamais
agréable pour qui que ce soit de vivre
ces événements là le plus important
c'est de garder sa sérénité
vous avez tout gagné dans votre carrière
non j'ai perdu
gagner pas mal de titres mais j'ai aussi
perdu des titres importants mais on
retient le plus sûr que j'ai gagné mais
je suis pas malheureux de ce côté là
donc bien au contraire
silva regret je pas d'europe aucun
pourquoi c'est pas après se dire oui
mais si j'avais j'ai pas la réponse si
j'avais fait ça est ce que ça se
souvenant s'est passé je regarde jamais
dans le lot rétro ce qui m'intéresse
c'est aujourd'hui surtout
demain je suis fier de ce que j'ai
réalisé mes 6 ans moment il ya eu des
des échecs ou non réussite ça m'a permis
aussi de grandir et d'analysé des le
haut niveau voilà on retient celui qui
gagne on retient pas du tout qui est
finaliste mais ça m'est arrivé aussi
d'être finaliste plusieurs fois et ne
pas avoir eu la cerise sur le gâteau du
monde en tant que joueur je suis
attaquée non ça booste la coupe d'europe
qui arrive championnats d'europe le
d'europe quelques mois maintenant un
accord il faut se qualifier
chaque chercheur au centre pour le
moment n'est pas qualifié on est sur la
bonne voie on n'est pas très contents
d'avoir autant de succès c'est la
passion intacte
je me suis pas posé la question après le
titre mondial parce que je suis
peut-être jeunes entre guillemets en
tant que c'est en tant que sélectionneur
pourtant comme puisque le demi siècle
est passé mais à partir du moment où la
sept patients est intacte
le jour où elle sera moins dans
certainement je passerai à autre chose
ou jeu j'arrêterai de deux mois mais ont
peut-être voir l'euro 2009 je ne me pose
pas de questions
aujourd'hui je vais pas renoncer pas ça
sert à rien de se rejeter la coupe du
monde la coupe d'europe
non non non il ya toujours quelque chose
après c'est qu'après la coupe du monde
qu'est ce qu'il ya non il n'y a rien qui
au dessus ça c'est clair ça c'est clair
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'ils a rien
d'intéressant et d'excitant à faire
chaque chose en son temps il faut aller
par étapes ne pas oublier de pas se voir
déjà l'euro et encore moins un champion
d'europe
aujourd'hui on est dans une tente de
passage où on doit se qualifier c'est
bien d'eux
dalé par étape et c'est un peu le mal du
du sport français en général c'est quand
on se voit déjà arriver de la pâte à
pain j'ai payé aussi je passais par là
c'est quelque chose qui est très
douloureux donc je suis surtout pas
envie de le revivre de le faire vivre à
mes joueurs parlent du mal du sport
français il ya un sujet dont on parle
beaucoup en ce début de saison c'est la
lutte contre l'homophobie dans les
stades
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi je sais pas
le je suis désolé c'est pas le mot
phobie ces discriminations pourquoi
ressortir le mot phobique plutôt qu'une
autre
où le racing c'est toutes les
discriminations quelles qu'elles soient
elles ont pas de place c'est pas dans le
football et dans le sport en général
il ya des choses qui se passaient qui se
passe c'est faire en sorte en concertant
un peu tout le monde pour que ça arrive
moins dans un premier temps et en
espérant que ça n'arrive plus je
voudrais pas ressortir non pas que après
c'est autrement mettre un curseur et
dire oui mais cette discrimination là
est plus importante ou moins importants
toutes les discriminations quelles
qu'elles soient
parce que le sport pour moi et le
football qui le sport le plus populaire
c'est certainement un le meilleur moyen
d'unir et de réunir les gens elle fait
d'arrêter un match quand ils ont plus
que c'était une bonne idée
on a vu ces derniers temps à partir du
moment où il ya eu deux stades et des
idées à un moment il ya des
c'est la responsabilité des instances de
dire stop
après moi je peux avoir mon propre avis
de dire là il faut aller là il fallait
pas c'est toujours il y aura toujours
des pour et des contres à un moment
quand on veut lutter contre quelque
chose oui il faut prendre des décisions
des décisions qui soit forte mais je
suis pas là pour dire oui là il fallait
le faire là il faut pas le faire chacun
peut avoir un avis et pas forcément
détenir la vérité et c'est au contraire
réunir tout le monde pour que ça arrive
moins dans un premier temps jusqu'à que
ça n'arrive plus du tout